[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de VIP
aujourd'hui j'ai le grand plaisir de
recevoir Alison Laurent c'est une
styliste créatrice spécialisée dans
l'upside clean la mode éco-responsable
Alison Laurent bonjour Merci d'avoir
recevoir merci d'être venu ça me fait
très plaisir vous êtes à Versailles
depuis 16 ans vous avez un atelier
boutique tout à fait voilà en fait je
suis à Versailles depuis 92 je suis
américaine d'origine mais je suis
arrivée en 1992 à l'école d'archives de
Versailles
je suis architecte donc de formation
mais j'ai compris que dans la vie
quotidienne d'un architecte qui avait
pas beaucoup de créativité finalement
donc j'ai préféré me réorienter et en
effet ça fait 16 ans que j'ai un atelier
boutique au centre ville de Versailles
alors vous avez refait une formation de
styliste ou non
c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de
parallèles entre l'architecture et le
modélisme c'est un travail de volume
c'est un travail de matière les couleurs
c'est juste ce sont les échelles qui
sont différentes évidemment l'impact
aussi mais j'avoue que c'est une échelle
que je préfère parce que je suis en plus
pas très patiente comme personne donc
c'est une échelle où je peux agir plus
rapidement d'accord à mon échelle à moi
je comprends oui vous avez vite le
résultat de votre travail tout à fait on
n'a pas besoin d'attendre des mois pour
voir les réalisations
de tellement énervant j'imagine alors
dites moi est-ce que vous vous êtes tout
de suite orienté quand vous avez ouvert
votre boutique vous êtes dit qu'est-ce
que je fais non parce que c'est quelques
années avant d'ouvrir à Versailles
j'avais déjà des points devant à Paris
donc en fait ça fait presque 20 ans que
je crée des pièces uniques à partir des
textiers des récupération et oui voilà
au départ j'ai des déposé dans les
boutiques à Paris des concepts c'était à
l'époque surtout des créations pour
enfants parce que j'avais des petits des
enfants en bas âge donc ça m'inspirait
au fil des années ça évolué maintenant
que les enfants sont grands et puis en
fait j'avais envie de tenter moi-même un
atelier boutique je me suis comme ça si
jamais ça marche pas en moi j'aurais
tenté mon coup je vais bientôt ça va
faire 16 ans
elle a comment donc vous aviez
suffisamment de matériaux de matière
pour pouvoir
upside clé alors ce que je disais hier
dans ma chronique upside clé c'est c'est
revaloriser finalement c'est transformé
en mieux alors en mieux et vraiment
c'est prendre une matière qui est arrivé
en fin de première vie et lui donner une
nouvelle vie
moi je suis chineuse et collectionneuse
depuis toujours une base de voilà tout à
fait par exemple j'ai toujours aimé les
objets et les textiles anciens
c'est mon enfance je pense entre autres
dans le Midwest autour des Grands Lacs
Michigan et j'étais réveillée dans une
famille où on récupère tout mon père
surtout est issu d'une très grande
famille il avait 7 frères et soeurs
voilà donc il y avait pas des gaspillage
et j'étais élevé dans cette idée là il y
a pas de gaspillage donc on récupère
tout qui peut être encore utilisé et on
lui transforme exactement tout à fait
donc j'avais déjà un peu de matière pour
commencer mon travail et puis au fil des
années les gens ont entendu parler de ma
démarche et spontanément ils viennent à
la boutique et me dépose les choses dont
il ne veut plus les rideaux en vidant la
maison de la vie étanche voilà tout ce
qui tout ce qui la famille ne veut pas
récupérer et moi je suis toujours
contente parce que c'est autant de
choses qui ne vont pas finir à la
poubelle déjà et vous arrivez après à
vous en inspirer pour pour des vêtements
uniques des pièces uniques en fait
toujours des vêtements voilà tout à fait
tout simplement parce que souvent dans
la quantité de matière il n'y a pas de
quoi faire deux pièces par an et donc
autant faire des pièces uniques que nous
sommes tous différents pourquoi de
porter tous la même chose ce serait
triste OK et alors comment on réagit vos
clients vos premières clients parce que
c'était autant à Versailles vous avez
des dépôt-vente ça ça existe oui mais
vous vous êtes la seule à faire ça
finalement en effet à Versailles j'étais
la seule au fil des années c'est devenu
plus dans l'air du temps
donc je suis pas la seule napsacqueline
maintenant mais peut-être toujours la
seule en vêtement en tout cas c'est vrai
qu'au départ je parlais moins de
obsèques que line déjà parce qu'il y a
16 ans je suis même pas sûr que on
parlait de obsèques clean je parlais des
tissus vintage parce que vintage c'était
déjà quelque chose qu'on pouvait
reconnaître en effet dans les matières
surtout ce que je récupère qui est
ancien et vraiment des matières de
qualités de nylon enfin alors moi je
prends tout parce que je ne veux pas que
ça se termine à la poubelle mais c'est
vrai que je préfère du coup je les
applique quand même bon mais
différemment différemment des petites
touches et puis évidemment je préfère
quand même des belles matières anciennes
mais mais vraiment je pense qu'il faut
qu'on utilise tout ce qu'on a
donc les clients au départ étaient pas
sceptiques mais c'est vrai que l'idée
était étrange et au fil des années bah
ils ont adopté l'idée et par contre je
peux dire que on ne vient pas toujours
chez moi uniquement pour ma démarche
éco-responsable j'ai des clientes qui
viennent et j'ai la chance parce qu'ils
aiment beaucoup ce que je fais mais
quelque part parfois ma démarche ne leur
ne leur ne les intéresse pas trop et
donc c'est une raison pour lesquelles
j'aime bien faire des événements pour
expliquer ce que c'est
au grand public et alors justement vous
êtes créatrice aussi de défiler depuis
quelques années déjà voilà le prochain
et pour bientôt ça sera le 13 14 mai
voilà mais vous en faites tous les ans
j'ai l'impression oui alors souvent les
maisons de couture ils font deux défilés
par an moi c'est une des fils un défilé
à peu près tous les 18 mois parce que
c'est énormément de travail voilà alors
celui-ci va être un peu particulier
parce qu'il va se trouver à la mairie de
Versailles qui vous prête la grande
salle des mariages très belle salle
voilà ça fait ouvert à tout le monde
exactement voilà et si on loupe celui-là
il y aura celui de la dans 18 mois il y
en aura un autre tout à fait d'accord
c'est que vous avez invité d'autres
créateurs qui ont deuxième démarche de
éco-responsable vous pouvez nous en
parler un peu des autres oui donc en
effet ça fait des années que je demande
à la mairie un partenariat pour
justement réaliser ces événements qui
sont pour moi culturels et écologiques
et ils ont accepté en mode collectif
donc nous sommes dit créateurs qui
étaient qui ont tous postulé un appel à
candidature c'était l'appel à
candidature était ouvert à tous mais
avec une charte très précise au niveau
éco-responsabilités fabrication
française et puis une marche
supplémentaire par rapport à fabrication
française ça pourrait être dû
obserculine ça peut être du circuit
court
ça peut être du bio sourcing il y a
plein de façons d'être éco-responsable
il n'y a pas que du obsèques clean mais
il se trouve que dans les créateurs qui
participent pour une grande majorité
c'est du obsèques d'accord c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que vous avez organisé enfin
vous proposer aux gens s'ils ont des des
vêtements ou des bijoux cassés dont ils
n'ont plus que faire de les apporter
vous les récolterez avec plaisir tout à
fait parce que dans les créateurs il y a
des créateurs de vêtements d'accessoires
et de bijoux et donc lors du défilé si
le cœur vous en dit vous pouvez venir
avec une pièce textile même abîmée
bijoux même abîmés ou bien les
emballages plastiques car il y a une des
créatrice qui crée des très jolies
bijoux à partir des emballages
plastiques donc nous on va prendre en
charge tous ces objets là et peut-être
que la prochaine fois vous allez les
voir dans une nouvelle vie et emballages
plastiques c'est de couleur voilà parce
que les emballages transparentes c'est
moins facile à retravailler ok très bien
et alors qu'est-ce que vous qui avez des
enfants adolescents qu'est-ce qu'ils
pensent de cette mode comment il
s'habille vos enfants alors mes enfants
alors j'ai deux garçons et une fille
les garçons ils se trouvent que ils sont
pas très intéressés du tout par le mode
donc ils sont très peu consommateurs et
ça me va très bien parce que c'est le
problème avec l'industrie actuelle la
mode c'est que ça pousse à la
surconsommation
ma fille bien sûr elle adore la mode
mais elle est éco-responsable depuis que
elle a commencé à choisir ses propres
vêtements elle achète des pièces
d'occasion elle me demande de temps en
temps de créer des petites pièces pour
elle elle échange elle fait du troc avec
des amis avec ses cousines donc elle est
vraiment dans cette démarche aussi et je
suis très contente de voir que la jeune
génération est très sensible à cette
idée parce que c'est un très très gros
problème la surconsommation de mode de
vêtements de oui parce que en ce moment
on en parle beaucoup ça fait 10 ans
depuis le désastre
en Angleterre d'angladesh où il y a plus
de 1000 personnes qui sont mortes dans
l'effondrement de l'usine textile
mais aussi des des droits de l'homme qui
sont totalement bafoués sans parler de
tous les milliers et des milliers de
kilomètres que voyagent c'est juste
horrible donc il faut vraiment qu'on
change et c'est urgent ben oui et ça
sera la nouvelle génération je pense de
prendre tout ça en main après c'est pas
toujours évident on n'est pas tous
obligés de s'habiller en vêtements
obsèques lignes d'occasion etc on a le
droit d'avoir des vêtements neufs mais
tout à fait le temps je pense c'est de
contrairement à cette marque mettons
Shine Shine je consigne
c'est de savoir d'où vient alors
les grandes marques et quand j'ai des
grandes marques je veux dire une marque
de grande diffusion je parle pas de
grandes marques en tant que qualité ils
sont beaucoup des greenwashing donc
c'est très difficile de savoir
franchement
ou sont fabriqués des vêtements
communiquer sur leur démarche
éco-responsable alors que ça cache la
réalité
des marques grandes diffusion il y a
aussi d'autres marques aussi qui se
présentent en tant que marque
éco-responsable fabrication française et
c'est pas du tout fabriqué en France
donc c'est très compliqué
c'est très difficile de contrôler en
fait parce que quelquefois il suffit
j'imagine une toute petite chose c'est
bon pour dire
donc le mieux c'est de tout simplement
consommer raisonnablement oui mais
comment être sûr que le vêtement qu'on
achète neuf c'est compliqué voilà après
on peut faire des recherches recherche
en ligne mais
je reconnais c'est compliqué et il y a
les difficultés du prix c'est ça alors
est-ce que à bas prix c'est forcément
fait par des enfants il y a des grandes
chances que ce soit pas du et qu'on
responsable voilà
et pour plein de raisons en France on a
les prix de
le travail c'est beaucoup plus cher que
sur d'autres pays ça beau voyagé moi ça
va revenir plus cher mais une fine et si
on achète moins de pièces qu'on peut
porter plus longtemps mais on fait des
économies sur donc ça vaut le coup de
payer un peu plus cher pour quelque
chose de qualité qu'on peut garder dans
le placard et porter avec joie pendant
plus longtemps
c'est un peu la démarche d'agnès b aussi
c'est ce qu'elle prône
temporelles
et vous vous avez une phrase j'avais
noté hier c'est les meilleures créations
sont celles qui qui ne créent pas de
nouvelles matières voilà il y a assez de
textiles qui existent déjà dans le monde
je pense vraiment il faut qu'on arrête
un produire bon après tout le monde
n'est pas vos talents de cette
couturière et
pardon et des boutiques comme la vôtre
finalement il y en a peut-être pas assez
là à Versailles en effet il y a pas
beaucoup à Paris et après Thor mais il y
a des petits événements ponctuels des
pop-up store des petits marchés des
créateurs ça vaut le coup de passer par
là et d'essayer de soutenir des petits
créateurs qui font des efforts pour
changer la mode vous avez envie de
parler de quelques créateurs qui seront
avec vous alors voilà on a fait 10 tous
les cités ça va faire beaucoup
Damien Béal qui est un verset à
Versailles c'est l'ébéniste maroquinier
qui fait des accessoires en cuir et en
bois en effet sa démarche
éco-responsable et circuit court donc
justement un de ces produits
à Versailles il y a aussi Cindy fontaine
qui fait des bijoux optiques et donc
elle prend des bijoux anciens mais pas
que parfois des chaînes de luxe vraiment
ça peut être très varié c'est magnifique
qui crée aussi unique avec du laiton
oxyclé
donc il y a plusieurs créateurs de
bijoux il y a des il y a une créatrice
japonaise d'origine Yumiko mutapa elle
est récupère des kimonos anciens de chez
elle parce que les kimonos se réaliser
dans les tissus magnifiques souvent qui
passent de génération en génération et
ces tissus parfois s'abîmes avec l'âge
parce que ce sont des tissus délicats et
donc elle récupère ce qui est encore
utilisable et créer des écharpes des
sacs aussi des pochettes des choses
magnifiques c'est génial voilà et après
si on veut retrouver tous ces créateurs
alors vous allez pouvoir déjà des
rencontrer lors du défilés en effet ils
ont tous des sites ou des
pages insta par exemple ils sont pas
tous présentes dans les boutiques il y a
une fille je tiens à parler d'elle ça va
mood c'est une créatrice solaire
actuellement les concours pour les
écoles de mode et je suis très contente
qu'elle participe parce qu'il représente
la jeune génération qui va justement
devoir rectifier l'industrie de la mode
parce que là actuellement en marche sur
la tête avec le système et donc elle je
sais pas du tout ce qu'elle va présenter
c'est pas encore une créatrice mais j'ai
vu son boucle c'est très poétique donc
je pense qu'il y aura des très belles
choses c'est bien que les jeunes comme
vous dites s'y mettent parce que c'est
eux la relève maintenant et c'est eux
qui vont subir
les effets néfastes de notre système
actuel il faut aussi que ça se développe
ses créateurs
il faut que les écoles de mode mettent
l'accent là-dessus c'est le cas ou pas
je n’étends pas la dent j'ai je ne sais
pas mais j'ai l'impression que c'est
pour dans des écoles de mode vous bah
oui mais bien sûr
Laurent un grand merci c'est moi qui
remercie à très vite et puis si on veut
pas aller au défilé on peut aller dans
votre atelier boutique
donc c'est très bel écran qui nous est
prêté par la mairie de Versailles voilà
merci la mairie merci la mairie merci à
vous c'est passionnant et on vous
soutient c'est gentil merci beaucoup
belle initiative ciao Alison à bientôt
au revoir à tous merci de nous avoir
suivi
[Musique]